back on January 16th we did the story
about a male sex robot that was called
to my attention that sort of looks like
me and after we ran that story I got an
email from a viewer named Ken who said
that story you did with the male sex
doll that looks like you gave me an idea
as to what a future patreon goal should
be you should purchase the sex doll and
at a patreon goal of your choosing
whether it be thirty five hundred or
whatever you do an entire show with the
doll dressed in a suit and sitting in
your chair you would be off-camera
lending your voice to discuss the
stories as usual but it would be the
doll in place of where you usually sit I
think it would be kind of funny
especially when you start talking to Pat
and he has to respond to an inanimate
doll just a thought thanks and keep up
the great work this is actually a
hilarious idea we make a patreon goal
like 5,000 patrons yeah and when we hit
that we buy the sex doll that looks like
me put my clothes on it and have it sit
here and it's here motionless and I do
an entire show from off-camera just with
a microphone and maybe it's even funnier
if we never talked about it we never
explain it in any way I'm always on
board for these ideas I like it the only
problem is that I went to the website
for real bottom annular is this thing
and there's not even a way to preorder
one right now yeah so that's a problem
so then what I did is I went to the real
doll website to check prices they seem
to cost between six and nine thousand
dollars roughly although they don't have
one that looks like me so what I thought
might be possible and again I'm just
kind of spitballing ideas here some of
these real doll type manufacturers they
will map they will make it look like
whoever you want so instead of going
with the real biotics one which just
seems to look like me by chance we could
actually have one made custom yeah
that really looks like they're gonna
think that you're a narcissist though
yes I know yeah but anyway listen if the
audience doesn't like this and it's
possible that they won't
I apologize let's never speak of it
again whatever but if we can get to
5,000 patrons it would certainly make
sense financially to invest six to nine
thousand in a doll but if we do buy this
I think we're stuck with it because I
don't
the resale value is zero but I have to
imagine theorem we'd have to pay someone
to take it although although although
it's possible we might be able to maybe
raffle it off to the audience or
included in some kind of oh yeah there's
a noise for that yeah it's possible that
someone in the audio if you listen to
our voice mail each day you'd probably
come away thinking that there are people
in the audience who would be interested
in a david pakman real doll sex doll
thing or something like that anyway send
me your thoughts and I know it's a
little silly but we're always looking
for unique and interesting things I
don't think you're going to tune into
Infowars and so in Alex Jones real doll
sitting there this is unique and
interesting for better or worse you're
not going to see that there so let me
know what your thoughts are and we can
go from there